The question of whether incitement to riot is animpeachable offense is pretty easy.
Clearly, yes.
From the beginning of this not normalpresidency,
we've had a lot of talk about both impeachment and the 25th Amendment.
In mostordinary circumstances, if you can use thatphrase in this context,
the 25th Amendment isa really a poor tool for removing a president.
It was really designed for presidents that werenearly completely incapacitated, Woodrow Wilson,
after the stroke, James Garfield, dying ofblood poisoning after the assassination attempt.
It wasn't supposed to get rid of bad Presidents.
We will stop the steal.
All along during the Trump presidency, whenthis solution has been proposed,
I thought it was pretty unrealistic for a couple of reasons.
The framers of the 25th Amendment deliberately made it harder to do than impeachment.
Impeachment only requires a super majority in the Senate forconviction, a majority in the House.
In order forthe switch, under the 25th Amendment, to stick
it has to be ratified by Congress, and that requires a super majority in both houses.
If you do have a super majority in both houses, thenyou could just impeach him.
And that's really the remedy.
I think we may be in a different situation here, though.
One of the main advantages, perhaps the only advantage,
that the 25th Amendment offers over impeachment is speed.
If Mike Pence waswilling to do this, and he had a majority of the cabinet behind him,
you could do it in the next20 minutes.
And it takes effect immediately.
In the past I’ve thought that one scenario where you might favor this
is if the President were to givethe order to launch an unprovoked nuclear strike.
I certainly hope we are not in that sort ofsituation here, but you can understand
why people would worry about it.
The argument for a25th Amendment solution here would be well,
how lucky do you feel?
Are we sure that what happened at the Capitol, after Trump's riot rally speech,
are we sure that that was peak Trump?
In the remaining few days of his presidency, that's the worst we're going to see.
Maybe it is.
Do you want to think about how much you're willing to stake on that proposition?
The argument fora last minute impeachment is a little different.
What impeachment does is it puts an additionalblack mark on a presidency,
an additional mark of disgrace and shame.
And it's a signal to the presidents that are going to follow
that this black mark can be put on you evenat the last moments of your presidency,
if your behavior has been egregious enough.
Making Donald Trump the only president to have been
impeached twice would really underscore thatpoint.
I've long thought that America should impeach presidents more often,
and perhaps thispresident more often.
Impeachment is a broad remedy.
High crimes and misdemeanors is a term of art that was designed to reach,
and historically has reached, a wide variety of offenses thatgo to the person's fitness for high office.
Hamilton talked about impeachment in terms of themisconduct of public men,
and said that it could notnot be limited in the way that criminal offenseswere limited.
Madison said the impeachment was the indispensable remedy for incapacity, negligence,
or perfidy in the chief magistrate.
It was not viewed, as it too often is today,as itself an agent of constitutional crisis.
Impeachment was viewed as the solution to a constitutional crisis.
If anything, I think they would be surprisedthat we've resorted to it so infrequently.
One thing that has always troubled me isthis argument that well, impeachment,
it's like a coup.
It's terribly anti-democratic. It's disruptive.
When you look at the events of the last week or so, I don't ever want to hear again,
that it's impeachment that's a constitutionalcrisis.
That it's impeachment, that's disruptive,and anti-democratic.
I think that argument deserves to be laughed out of court,
given what we've experienced over the last few days.